estábamos tranquilos aquí todos los que
estamos mirando el partido todos los
hinchas de Argentina mirando las
pantallas en ese primer tiempo cómodo
que parecía que Francia no hacía nada
pero Francia tiene aquí mbappé y la
verdad era Argentina contra mbappé fue
Argentina contra mbappé y mbappé sufrir
a la selección argentina hasta el último
minuto como siempre decimos aquí sufrido
sufrido para Argentina Pero al final se
consiguió sin duda es una gran selección
Nadie puede discutir que merecía Y
quiero tomar una alegría global
especialmente tal vez no por Argentina
pero sí por la figura de Lionel Messi
natalio a lo largo de la semana después
de la clasificación en la semifinal a
este partido había mucho optimismo había
mucha emoción había mucha expectativa
para los argentinos pero en cualquier
escenario positivo se habían imaginado
que el partido sería así
yo creo que no creo que había un poco
más como de esperanza de que iba a ser
un poco más fácil y ese primer tiempo
como te decía daba esa sensación de
bueno Esta es una selección que no nos
va a hacer sufrir pero parece que la
camiseta trae el ADN del sufrimiento
adentro y tocó un poco sufrir un poco
mucho sufrir en esta final y en algo que
se veía en los rostros de los hinchas
que seguían aquí en una zona de bares el
partido de esta gran final en Qatar y
ahora natalio que le espera al fanático
A dónde es el citro de concentración
donde se celebra en Argentina un título
tan importante como este
[Música]
cuando ganó argentina se juntó muchísima
gente en el epicentro de la ciudad que
es el obelisco de hecho ya hay todo un
procedimiento de seguridad con calles
cortadas alrededor de algo que estaba
previsto desde las 14 horas de Buenos
Aires a también hay algunas
restricciones de transporte mucha gente
ya estaba en el obelisco durante el
partido algunos empezaron a ir caminando
O de la forma que puedan para celebrar
seguramente la celebración se extiende
durante lo que resta del día y la noche
y se espera tal vez Lunes o martes la
llegada de los jugadores para hacerles
aquí en Buenos Aires
que esta gente le quiere dar a su
selección